i'm surprised that like every single
death in the u.s hasn't had a
docu-series at this rate like yeah
everything has been covered at this
point yeah honestly i just don't it's
crazy like i watched one the other day
about like some uh grandma who uh was
killing people in her house and i was
like
how are they finding this stuff who's
finding this this is insane why was this
not televised earlier i feel like i
should know about this grandma are
killing people this feels like a
tv show plot yeah this happens on tv
would be like unrealistic
obviously you don't watch enough true
crime documentaries or true crime
podcasts or channels because yeah the
true crime podcast is like being in
there yeah i've been there done that
because i i feel like there's this basic
the obsession sometimes you're watching
true crime you're like
and then you just get this moment of
like your your consciousness going don't
you think it's weird that you're
watching stories about people being
murdered and they're just shoving
cameras in their face and interrogating
people to tell tell us how they felt 20
years ago when their family member died
like do you not get that when you watch
it yeah definitely i feel like i get
these moments i'll watch a full series i
won't get it every now and then i'll
just watch a series and it's always with
the family interviews where it kind of
makes me think
what why are they just making these
family members just like [ __ ] talk
about their [ __ ] and cry on camera yeah
yeah oh like they're like
i loved him and stuff and it's like it's
genuine right and i feel like these
these poor people who like yeah didn't
ever want to talk about this again i've
just been shoved with it because they're
probably when someone was like here's 10
grand talk about your dead cousin yeah
and how they were close to you and how
it was suspicious that that one guy who
never got caught was just you know that
brutal model that you saw in front of
your eyes recall that yeah word for word
and it's just the same formula as well
yeah i don't know it feels like we've
turned it into a sort of
occasion like yeah we've glorified
murder and stuff and
yeah that's that's scary i feel like
like because sydney i've talked about
this before but sydney listens to a lot
a lot of like true crime videos true
crime podcast whenever like she's doing
her makeup and stuff like that and like
every so every time he
dis-discombobulated him
every so often i'd be like and then
david trapped sally in her basement for
two weeks and brutally
her before
her and
her but before i get to the next point
i'd like to bring up my sponsor for
today's video nordvpn and i'm just like
brah
what is this right now okay like i i get
it like you know like the you know an
expo
i don't want to end up like sally right
you should get an old vpn i don't know
if these guys like i don't even have an
expo i know rainbow has sponsors and
stuff like certainly i understand like
yeah i get it but it you have to admit
like
it is it's so jarring when i just hear
about this this like i love your
channels by the way i love your guys's
videos
but there's right and wrong places to
put it i don't know it's so wet i don't
think there's ever like uh unfortunately
the topic i think just doesn't lend one
yeah it just doesn't land well but like
there's there's been weird transitions i
mean we've done very many weird
transitions in i'm sure in our careers
with like just transitioning to a uh
sponsor that we've had for this video
the berserk thing one time right we were
talking about the passing of uh mira
oh yeah and because the way that we
recorded it uh there was an ad break
that was put right in the middle of us
talking about
something that we looked over um
but there's yeah it's
not any like true crime
true crime youtubers there i don't know
i don't think there is a right way to
transition from some of the stuff they
talk about to an advertiser yeah every
time i hear it it's just like it just
takes me out for a second it's just like
we've i don't know in a way i i
it's totally fine and i don't think it's
like bad i'm not condemning it no i'm
not condemning it i like i like the
content yeah but like you have to admit
sometimes you're watching it and you're
like it is strange how we've turned this
into like it's it's like the common
common day watch mojo yeah we've turned
in like that we've turned murders into
what we we like top tens used to fill
like
whereas top ten used to fill that i'll
just put anything on kind of thing yeah
just like murder and horrible acts just
let it fill the void somehow
like there's a there's like channels i'm
surprised watching mojo hasn't gone into
that yeah there's top 10 like girls
who've been trapped in dungeons this
probably is something i know that
there's people who do their makeup and
talk about true crime that's a call yeah
yeah yeah i've seen that a lot yeah
which is also a strange evolution but
impressive it's like get ready with me
while i talk about this it's horrible
it's like cool
it's like next level mukbang right but
they're just
they're doing makeup and they're talking
about true colors i want to see a
mukbang where they talk about true crime
as they're like just demolishing a pilot
this digestive system jesus christ yeah
i mean again like i i watch a lot of it
i consume a lot of it but i do just get
those moments where i'm like
yeah the reality hits right yeah
it is weird especially where like i
thought about it the other day and i'm
like i don't know anyone
in my immediate circle or relatives or
anything
where somebody has had like something
really horrible happen to them or a
murder
i don't know do you know anyone
like a cousin who knows someone who's
been murdered or something like that no
not when it comes to murder and like
this this true crime stuff almost kind
of like normalizes it in your mind i
feel like that this is a normal thing
that happens i don't think in fact it
isn't normal no and i think it
normalizes it it just desensitizes you
to it yeah well i mean it makes you
think that it is a normal thing that
happens really i've never heard of like
i've never listened to true crime and
thought it was a normal thing that
happened like you watch it these are
real people like yeah yeah these people
these interviews this could be your this
could be your cousin this could be your
mom like this i think i think it's the
gravity at which they address that
particular topic where it's like they
say like oh yeah so uh tim got murdered
like
in the same tone as like yeah so i met
up with bob the other day you know yeah
it's like i think yeah i think the
gravity of the situation is often lost
yeah in in the content because there's
so much content like that yeah yeah the
content is king and yeah and i'm not
saying that i want to sit there and feel
traumatized every single time i watch
something about true crime i just think
it's kind of interesting and worth
talking about the fact that we don't
consume it and we don't
empathize
necessarily always yeah i mean it is
entertainment in
in a sense right it is entertainment we
do we don't watch it to really how can i
say it's really
we don't we don't watch it
to not sympathize but we don't watch it
people don't watch these kinds of
documentaries and cry at the end of it
right is what you know like they don't
they're not like oh my god i feel so sad
for these like families let's start we
watch out of morbid curiosities yeah
like there's there's a sense of
morbidness to it where we want to know
the
gross details how did curiosity go
though that's the question that's the
question well that's when you start
getting into the weird [ __ ] right yeah
yeah and uh that's the part where it's
like oh okay
yeah to the point where it's like oh
true you liking true crime documentaries
is nothing compared to like
some of the weirdest stuff you're into
sometimes i wonder like
like do
i i think i'm consuming this content
wrong
because i've watched some things where
it'll be like a documentary and it'll be
like oh yeah like a kid got like beat up
by his parents and no one helped him and
then the kid died and it's like i have
to like stop for the day yeah i'm like i
have to like take a yeah i have to like
just step back and be like [ __ ] yeah i
can't do anything but then people watch
like tons of these and i'm like i'm
wondering like what are they
experiencing that's different from me
yeah like that that makes it so that i
walk away from this just feeling drained
and exhausted yeah and they're like oh
next one
yeah
one thing i found really just want to
know like yeah one thing i found really
interesting is that japan doesn't have
any programming like that no they don't
they don't i've noticed that yeah and i
think it's because it's taboo yeah it is
it is taboo to like bring it back up and
talk about it and especially like you
know i can't imagine a [ __ ] tv
program being like knock knock no okay
your son got murdered 10 years ago talk
about it like you know like they want to
respect the families right yeah it's
like not saying that you know all of
these like two true crime documentary
makers have no respect on the families
or whatever but it is scarily like
it is
yeah and it's scary that no one who
watches that kind of programming second
guesses that invasiveness but also i
understand maybe if somebody was your
family was murdered i can also
understand the the opposite where being
able to talk about it and express your
faith
can help you get like grieve and help
you kind of get the story out there and
you feel like i've told my case i've
told people what it is and i'm sure both
sides yeah and i'm sure you know the
ones who think that oh if i just talk
about it on camera and get it off my
chest and let people hear it it would
make me feel better the other ones that
turn into documentaries that's why i
kind of get worried with these sorry
i've interrupted you like three times in
a row now
the final time i promise i promise
unprofessionally
i said like most of the time i had like
a point it was gone and i was like oh
man i have no point you guys can be like
connor look don't [ __ ] speak
you know that's another thing addressed
him i think a few of them here and there
is like this is where i i start to get a
bit weirded out with true crimes when
there's the true crime investigators
online that go around and then start you
know pushing buttons and sending emails
and asking people questions you don't
want to talk about it and it's like i
think people have it right warriors
keyboard investigations detectives what
was that [ __ ] what was that one where
that guy
oh
[ __ ] which one was it there was this guy
and he was like that the head detective
for the online
and um do you know what have you watched
this was sydney's probably definitely
[ __ ] laughing i got acid don't [ __ ]
that was with cats
one i know well that was actually a good
one yeah yeah there's been another one
where a guy
was just like a 4chan user or something
i needed i don't feel confident saying
about it i need to go and check
what it was on netflix there's one where
this guy was basically like like in
charge because the police weren't
helping that much but the police have to
go through you know systems and right
they don't always do the best job
obviously they have to go through the
procedure this guy kind of like
kind of steamrolled in and was like i'll
help you family i'll be the detective
and it was kind of weird watching this
documentary what was the family like
they were like oh yes they liked it
because because
they were in a vulnerable spot you know
this guy was selling them the thing that
i can help you know that's not cool but
but i think the guy genuinely believed
he could help i don't think he was a
scam or anything because there was no
money involved he was like i will help
you but it just felt kind of weird okay
i was about safe like he was like i'll
help you solve the case
he was like an internet guy who's just
really into true crime and he was going
about being like i will solve this i'll
help you do it oh okay [ __ ] i need to
figure out what this is i've i have a
such a vivid image of this guy i don't
know do you think that's morally correct
to do or
it might have been um i don't know it
really depends on the situation because
was this guy deluded or did this guy
actually help out i don't know what
brown's i guess what what uh from what
corners described what grounds did he
have to uh come to a family and was like
i can solve this crime do you want the
clout
wait so the next time he's on a true
crime
so uh you might have heard of this case
that was me it was from thai king too oh
there was this guy who was like oh yeah
i'm i'm definitely certain that uh carol
basking killed it yeah help i'll help
the family and stuff i'm just weird it
was like this guy's clearly just
inserting himself yeah in the situation
he just wants to be part of the
storyline he's just like it was just
like i just
[Music]
i don't know just leave it up to the
professionals yeah like to me i think i
get too invested in true crime stories
which is why i've never fully like been
into true crime uh because like i i
would hear some of the stuff that sydney
listens to or something and sometimes
they like actually play like the
this crime 911 i hear this [ __ ] and i'm
like take i'm just like fresh out of the
shower ready for my day or something and
i got like a cr like like a kid [ __ ]
crying on the phone telling like the
police that her mother's been murdered
or something i'm like and then you
immediately feel dirty i'm just like
sydney i want to cry now
can we not listen to what she's just
like
[Laughter]
like
i'm not we're not trying to imply that
if you if you do consume this stuff you
have no idea
no no no this is this is just like i get
too invested yeah i'm just wondering
like why is it different
it's interesting